ברוכים הבאים חזרה להבנת מידע קוונטי וחישוב, שמי John Watrous ואני המנהל הטכני לחינוך ב-IBM
Quantum. זהו שיעור מספר 14 בסדרה והשיעור השני ביחידה הרביעית שעוסקת בתיקון שגיאות
קוונטי. בשיעור הקודם הסתכלנו לראשונה על תיקון שגיאות קוונטי כולל קוד Shore בן 9 qubit-ים שמוכיח ש
תיקון שגיאות קוונטי אפשרי בתאוריה. דנו גם בדיסקרטיזציה של שגיאות שמאפשרת לנו
לתקן שגיאות קוונטיות שרירותיות על qubit-ים על ידי הטלתן ביעילות על היפוכי ביטים והיפוכי
פאזה. בשיעור הזה נדון בפורמליזם המייצבים שהוא כלי מתמטי שדרכו אפשר
לציין ולנתח מחלקה רחבה של קודים לתיקון שגיאות קוונטיות שנקראים קודי מייצבים. זה כולל את קוד Shore בן 9 qubit-ים
יחד עם דוגמאות רבות אחרות, כולל קודים שסביר שיתאימו הרבה יותר להתקני חישוב
קוונטי בעולם האמיתי מאשר קוד Shore. לא כל קוד לתיקון שגיאות קוונטי הוא קוד מייצבים, אבל רבים כן,
כולל כל דוגמה שנראה בסדרה הזו. יש בהחלט קודים מעניינים ואולי שימושיים לתיקון שגיאות
קוונטיות שאינם קודי מייצבים, אבל הם נוטים להיות יותר מסובכים, ובכל מקרה אין
שאלה שפורמליזם המייצבים הוא אבן פינה ביסודות תיקון השגיאות הקוונטי, ונסתמך
עליו רבות לאורך שארית היחידה. הנה סקירה קצרה של השיעור. נתחיל עם דיון קצר
על מטריצות Pauli ומכפלות טנסוריות של מטריצות Pauli שיכולות לייצג הן פעולות על qubit-ים והן
מדידות של qubit-ים כפי שאסביר, ובהקשר הזה לעיתים קרובות מתייחסים אליהן כנצפים. אז נחזור ונסתכל
פעם שנייה על קוד החזרה ונראה איך אפשר לתאר אותו דרך פעולות ונצפי Pauli, וזה גם יאיר
וגם יוביל לדיון כללי על קודי מייצבים כולל מספר דוגמאות, תכונות בסיסיות של קודי
מייצבים ואיך אפשר לבצע את המשימות הבסיסיות של קידוד, זיהוי שגיאות ותיקון
שגיאות. נתחיל את השיעור עם דיון קצר על פעולות Pauli, בעיקר כדי להכין את הקרקע ל
פורמליזם המייצבים אבל גם כדי לציין כמה עובדות מפתח ולבסס טרמינולוגיה בסיסית. ראשית, הנה מטריצות
Pauli כולל מטריצת הזהות 2 על 2 וגם שלוש מטריצות Pauli שאינן זהות, שנסמן ב
X, Y ו-Z גדולות לאורך שארית הסדרה. כל ארבע המטריצות האלה הן גם יוניטריות וגם הרמיטיות, ואפשר
לזהות אותן עם פעולות על qubit, כולל פעולות שאולי נבחר לבצע וגם שגיאות כפי ש
דנו בשיעור הקודם. מטריצות Pauli שאינן זהות X, Y ו-Z אנטי-קומוטטיביות זו עם זו,
כלומר XY שווה למינוס 1 כפול YX, XZ שווה למינוס ZX, ו-YZ שווה
למינוס ZY. ואפשר בקלות לבדוק את הקשרים האלה על ידי ביצוע הכפלים. קשרי האנטי-קומוטטיביות
האלה מאוד פשוטים אבל הם חשובים באופן קריטי בפורמליזם המייצבים ובמקומות אחרים, וספציפית
כפי שנראה, סימני המינוס האלה שקופצים החוצה כשמחליפים את סדר שתי מטריצות Pauli שונות שאינן זהות במכפלה מתאימים בדיוק ל
זיהוי שגיאות בפורמליזם המייצבים. יש לנו גם את כללי הכפל הרשומים כאן. כל
מטריצת Pauli היא ההופכי של עצמה, מה שעקבי עם העובדה שהן גם יוניטריות וגם הרמיטיות. ואם מכפילים שתי מטריצות Pauli שונות שאינן זהות
תמיד מקבלים פלוס או מינוס i כפול מטריצת Pauli שאינה זהות ש
נותרה. בפרט, עד כדי פאזה גלובלית, Y שקולה ל-X כפול Z, מה שמסביר את ההתמקדות שלנו בשגיאות X ו-Z ב
תיקון שגיאות קוונטי. X מייצגת היפוך ביט, Z מייצגת היפוך פאזה, ואז עד כדי פאזה גלובלית Y מייצגת
את שתי השגיאות האלה המתרחשות על אותו qubit. כל ארבע המטריצות האלה מייצגות
פעולות או שגיאות או היעדר שגיאה על qubit בודד, אבל לעיתים קרובות נוח לעשות להן מכפלה טנסורית ביחד
כדי לבצע פעולות או שגיאות על מספר qubit-ים. מבחינת טרמינולוגיה, כשאנחנו מתייחסים לפעולת Pauli על N qubit-ים
הכוונה למכפלה טנסורית של כל N מטריצות Pauli כמו הדוגמאות שמוצגות
כאן. זה גם נפוץ להשתמש במונח פעולת Pauli כשיש פאזה גלובלית, אבל כדי לשמור על דברים פשוטים ככל האפשר
אני אשתמש במונח פעולת Pauli במשמעות של מכפלה טנסורית של מטריצות Pauli בלבד. המשקל של פעולת Pauli על N qubit-ים
הוא פשוט מספר מטריצות Pauli שאינן זהות במכפלה הטנסורית. לדוגמה, המכפלה הטנסורית של
מטריצת הזהות 2 על 2 עם עצמה N פעמים היא פעולת Pauli במשקל אפס. מכפלה טנסורית של שתי מטריצות Pauli-X
וערימה של מטריצות זהות היא במשקל שתיים, וכן הלאה. באופן אינטואיטיבי, המשקל של פעולת Pauli על N qubit-ים
הוא מספר ה-qubit-ים שעליהם היא פועלת באופן לא טריוויאלי. וזה אופייני שקודים לתיקון שגיאות קוונטיות מתוכננים
כך שיוכלו לזהות ולתקן שגיאות המיוצגות על ידי פעולות Pauli עד למשקל מסוים. אפשר
לחשוב על פעולות Pauli בדרכים שונות, כולל כפעולות שמבוצעות בכוונה על ידי gate-ים קוונטיים, וגם
כשגיאות. ובקרוב גם נראה שפעולות Pauli יכולות לתאר מדידות. לפעמים גם שימושי
לחשוב על פעולות Pauli כיוצרות של קבוצות מסוימות במובן אלגברי שאולי תזהו
אם אתם מכירים תורת החבורות. אם אתם לא מכירים תורת חבורות, זה בסדר, זה באמת לא חיוני
לשיעור הזה. אבל אם מעניין אתכם ללמוד תיקון שגיאות קוונטי לעומק, אולי תגלו שקצת
תורת חבורות בסיסית מאוד מועילה לזה. בכל מקרה, נניח ש-P1 עד PR הן פעולות Pauli על N qubit-ים,
אז P1 היא פעולת Pauli על N qubit-ים, P2 היא פעולת Pauli על N qubit-ים, וכן הלאה. כשמתייחסים לקבוצה הנוצרת על ידי
P1 עד PR, הכוונה לקבוצת כל המטריצות שאפשר לקבל על ידי הכפלת המטריצות האלה יחד ב
כל שילוב ובכל סדר שנבחר, כשלוקחים כל אחת כמה פעמים שנרצה. נראה כמה דוגמאות עוד
רגע, אבל קודם אזכיר את הסימון שמשתמשים בו לציון הקבוצה הזו: הקבוצה הנוצרת על ידי P1 עד PR, ו
זה P1 עד PR מופרדים בפסיקים בתוך סוגריים משולשים. זה אכן נראה כאילו אפשר לבלבל
את הסימון הזה עם סימון דירק, אבל זה בדרך כלל לא קורה וזה הסימון המסורתי בתורת
החבורות. הנה דוגמה לקבוצה הנוצרת על ידי X, Y ו-Z, אז N שווה ל-1 בדוגמה הזו כי אין
מכפלות טנסוריות ולוקחים את כל שלוש מטריצות Pauli שאינן זהות כיוצרות. מתברר שיש
16 מטריצות שאפשר ליצור על ידי יצירת מכפלות שכוללות את שלוש המטריצות האלה, ואפשר להסיק את זה
דרך כללי הכפל שראינו קודם. ספציפית כמובן שאפשר לקבל X, Y ו-Z וגם את הזהות,
ולמעשה אפשר גם לקבל כל אחת מארבע המטריצות האלה כפול i, 1 או מינוס i, וזהו.
הקבוצה הזו ידועה בשם חבורת Pauli. אפשר גם לשקול את הקבוצה
הנוצרת רק על ידי X ו-Z, ובמקרה הזה מקבלים חצי מחבורת Pauli.
ודוגמה אחרונה לעת עתה, אפשר לשקול את הקבוצה הנוצרת על ידי X טנסור X ו-Z טנסור Z, אז N שווה ל
2 במקרה הזה, ומקבלים רק ארבעה אלמנטים הפעם, בזכות העובדה ש-X טנסור X ו-Z טנסור Z
קומוטטיביים זה עם זה. מטריצות Pauli ופעולות Pauli על N qubit-ים באופן כללי יותר מתארות
פעולות יוניטריות בין אם הן שגיאות ובין אם הן מכוונות, אבל הן גם מתארות
מדידות. ליתר דיוק, אם מתחילים רק עם שלוש מטריצות Pauli שאינן זהות, אפשר לשייך לכל אחת מ
המטריצות האלה מדידה הטלתית המוגדרת במונחי הערכים העצמיים והוקטורים העצמיים שלה. וכאן על המסך
יש לנו פירוקים ספקטרליים של המטריצות האלה שיעזרו להבהיר את זה. בעצם כשמתייחסים ל
מדידת X, מדידת Y או מדידת Z הכוונה למדידה ההטלתית שמוגדרת על ידי ההטלות
על המרחבים העצמיים של המטריצות האלה, ובדרך כלל חושבים על הערכים העצמיים כתוצאות
המדידה המתאימות. לדוגמה מדידת X היא מדידה ביחס לבסיס
plus/minus של qubit, או לחלופין אפשר לתאר אותה על ידי הקבוצה שמכילה את ההטלות ket plus bra plus ו-ket
minus bra minus. מדידת Z מצד שני היא לא יותר ממדידת בסיס
סטנדרטי, אם כי כמו שאמרתי לפעמים מזהים את הערכים העצמיים עם תוצאות המדידה, ואם עושים
את זה אז התוצאות הן פלוס ומינוס 1 בניגוד ל-0 ו-1 בהתאמה. למעשה אפשר לעשות משהו
בסגנון הזה למטריצות הרמיטיות שרירותיות, והמונח נצפה נפוץ במצב כזה. עבור מטריצות
Pauli ופעולות Pauli על N qubit-ים באופן כללי יותר, אפשר לבצע מדידות כאלה באופן לא-הרסני באמצעות
הערכת פאזה. ורק כדי לוודא שהדיאגרמה הזו ברורה, כאן אנחנו מבצעים מדידות לא-הרסניות על
ה-qubit העליון, בעוד שה-qubit התחתון תמיד מאותחל למצב plus, או במילים אחרות Hadamard מופעל על מצב
אפס, כי ככה הערכת פאזה עובדת. שימו לב שבגלל שהערכים העצמיים
הם רק פלוס 1 ומינוס 1 במקרה הזה, צריך רק qubit בקרה אחד שהוא ה-qubit התחתון ב
דיאגרמה. יותר מזה זה סתם בזבוז כי יש רק ביט אחד של דיוק לדאוג לגביו. הערך העצמי
הוא או פלוס 1 או מינוס 1 והמדידה כבר מושלמת בדיוק ככה. התוצאה של המדידה הזו
אגב, כלומר מדידת הבסיס הסטנדרטי ב-circuit, תהיה 0 עבור תוצאת הערך העצמי פלוס 1
שמתאימה למצב plus במקרה של נצפה X, והתוצאה היא 1 עבור הערך העצמי מינוס 1
או מצב minus במקרה הזה. כל מה שאמרתי עכשיו מתרחב באופן טבעי לפעולות Pauli על N qubit-ים
בתנאי שזוכרים שכשחושבים על נצפה אנחנו מדברים על מדידת הערכים העצמיים
ולא מדידה ביחס לבסיס של וקטורים עצמיים. לדוגמה שקלו את פעולת
Pauli על 2 qubit-ים Z טנסור Z. שוב יש שני ערכים עצמיים, פלוס 1 ומינוס 1, אז
המדידה מתוארת על ידי שתי הטלות. שימו לב בפרט שהמדידה שאנחנו משייכים ל
נצפה הזה היא לא אותו דבר כמו למדוד את שני ה-qubit-ים עם מדידת Z, או במילים אחרות מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי, אלא זו מדידה
הטלתית עם שתי תוצאות כאשר ההטלות הן על המרחבים הנפרשים על ידי כל הוקטורים העצמיים המתאימים ל
כל אחד משני הערכים העצמיים, פלוס 1 ומינוס 1. דרך אחרת לחשוב על זה היא שהערכים העצמיים של מכפלה
טנסורית הם מכפלות של הערכים העצמיים של המטריצות הבודדות שלוקחים את המכפלות הטנסוריות שלהן, ו
בגלל שמינוס 1 כפול מינוס 1 זה אותו דבר כמו פלוס 1 כפול פלוס 1 למשל, המדידה הזו לא
מבחינה בין 00 ו-11. אז אם היינו מודדים נגיד מצב Bell phi plus עם המדידה
שמתוארת על ידי נצפה הזה, היינו בטוחים לקבל את התוצאה המתאימה לערך העצמי פלוס 1
והמצב היה נשאר ללא שינוי, בניגוד לקריסה ל-00 או 11, מה שהיה קורה אם
היינו מבצעים מדידות בסיס סטנדרטי על שני ה-qubit-ים. אז מדידת Z טנסור Z היא לא
אותו דבר כמו לבצע שתי מדידות Z באופן עצמאי. אבל כן אפשר לבצע מדידות כאלה באמצעות הערכת
פאזה בדיוק באותה דרך כמו קודם, עם qubit בקרה בודד כמו שמוצג בדיאגרמת ה-circuit, ש
מוכללת לכל פעולת Pauli על N qubit-ים במקום Z טנסור Z. כשיש רק מטריצות Pauli-Z
אגב, אפשר לפשט את ה-circuit ככה, ומה שזה חושף, שגם ברור מההטלות שמגדירות
את המדידה, הוא שביצוע מדידת Z טנסור Z על שני qubit-ים שקול למדידת הזוגיות שלהם
במונחים של הבסיס הסטנדרטי, וזה מוכלל למכפלה טנסורית של כל מספר של מטריצות
Pauli-Z. עכשיו נסתכל פעם שנייה על קוד החזרה של 3 ביטים, הפעם בניסוח במונחים של פעולות
Pauli. זו תהיה הדוגמה הראשונה והפשוטה שלנו לקוד מייצבים, ונדון באיך להכליל את
הרעיון הזה בקרוב. אבל זה מועיל לראות איך זה עובד במקרה הפשוט הזה קודם. נזכיר שכשמפעילים את
קוד החזרה של 3 ביטים על qubit-ים, מקודדים מצב qubit נתון אלפא 0 פלוס בטא 1 כ-אלפא 000 פלוס בטא 111,
וניתן לקידוד הזה של 3 qubit-ים את השם psi לנוחות. אז בהגדרה psi הוא קידוד תקף של 3 qubit-ים
למצב qubit. אבל אם רוצים לבדוק את זה, מספיק לבדוק ששתי המשוואות הבאות נכונות.
המשוואה הראשונה קובעת שהפעלת פעולות Z על שני ה-qubit-ים השמאליים ביותר של psi לא עושה כלום ל-psi, כלומר
psi הוא וקטור עצמי של Z טנסור Z טנסור Identity, או בקיצור ZZ-Identity, עם ערך עצמי 1. והמשוואה
השנייה דומה חוץ מזה שפעולות Z מופעלות על שני ה-qubit-ים הימניים ביותר. הרעיון הוא שאם חושבים על psi
כצירוף לינארי של מצבי בסיס סטנדרטי, אז המשוואה הראשונה גוררת שיכולים להיות מקדמים לא-אפסיים רק למצבי בסיס סטנדרטי
שבהם שני הביטים השמאליים ביותר בעלי זוגיות זוגית, או שקול, שווים. והמשוואה השנייה גוררת שיכולים להיות
מקדמים לא-אפסיים רק למצבי בסיס סטנדרטי שבהם שני הביטים הימניים ביותר בעלי זוגיות זוגית. דרך אחרת לחשוב על זה
היא לראות את שתי פעולות Pauli האלה כנצפים, ואם היינו מודדים את שני הנצפים האלה באמצעות ה-
circuit המפושט שהזכרתי לפני רגע, היינו בטוחים לקבל תוצאת מדידה המתאימה לערכים עצמיים פלוס 1
כי psi הוא וקטור עצמי של שני הנצפים עם ערך עצמי 1. אבל הגרסה המפושטת הזו של ה-circuit
המשולב למדידה עצמאית של הנצפים היא לא אחרת מאשר circuit בדיקת הזוגיות שלנו עבור קוד החזרה של 3 ביטים,
ולכן אנחנו רואים ששתי המשוואות שלנו יחד שקולות לכך שה-circuit של בדיקת הזוגיות מוציא 00
שהוא הסינדרום שמציין שלא זוהו שגיאות. פעולות Pauli על 3 qubit-ים
ZZ-Identity ו-Identity-ZZ נקראות יוצרות מייצבים עבור הקוד הזה, והמייצב של הקוד הוא הקבוצה
הנוצרת על ידי יוצרות המייצבים. הקבוצה הזו, המייצב, היא עצם מתמטי חשוב ביותר
שמשויך לקוד הזה, ונדון עוד בתפקיד שהוא ממלא ככל שהשיעור ממשיך. לעת עתה
רק אציין שהיינו יכולים לבחור בחירה שונה ליוצרות. למשל היינו יכולים לבחור Z-Identity-Z במקום אחת מ
היוצרות שבחרנו, והקוד והמייצב היו בדיוק אותו דבר. עכשיו נשקול זיהוי היפוכי
ביטים עבור קוד החזרה של 3 ביטים, עם דגש על האינטראקציות והקשרים בין פעולות
Pauli המעורבות, כלומר יוצרות המייצבים והשגיאות עצמן. נניח שקידדנו
qubit באמצעות קוד החזרה של 3 ביטים ושגיאת היפוך ביט מתרחשת על ה-qubit השמאלי ביותר. זה גורם למצב psi שלנו להיות
מומר לפי פעולת שגיאת X על ה-qubit השמאלי ביותר. כפי שכבר ידוע לנו, אפשר לזהות
את השגיאה הזו על ידי ביצוע בדיקות זוגיות עבור קוד החזרה של 3 ביטים, או שקול אפשר למדוד את
הקידוד באופן לא-הרסני תוך התייחסות ליוצרות המייצבים כנצפים. נתחיל עם יוצרת
המייצב הראשונה ונראה מה קורה. המצב שלנו הושפע משגיאת X ואנחנו רוצים להבין
איך המדידה של יוצרת המייצב כנצפה מושפעת מהשגיאה הזו. X ו-Z אנטי-קומוטטיביים, ואילו
הכול קומוטטיבי עם מטריצת הזהות, ולכן נובע ש-ZZ-Identity אנטי-קומוטטיבי עם X-Identity-Identity.
אז מקבלים סימן מינוס כשמשנים את הסדר, ואנחנו גם יודעים ש-ZZ-Identity לא עושה כלום ל-psi
כי psi הוא קידוד תקף של qubit, וקידודים תקפים הם תמיד וקטורים עצמיים של פלוס 1 של שתי יוצרות
המייצבים. מה שנשאר לנו הוא מינוס X-Identity-Identity מופעל על psi, ולכן X-Identity-Identity מופעל על
psi הוא וקטור עצמי של ZZ-Identity עם ערך עצמי מינוס 1. אפשר גם לעשות משהו דומה
עם יוצרת המייצב השנייה, אבל הפעם השגיאה קומוטטיבית עם יוצרת המייצב, ולכן
המצב הפגום שלנו הוא שוב וקטור עצמי של יוצרת המייצב, אבל הפעם הערך העצמי הוא חיובי
1. אז המצב הפגום שלנו הוא וקטור עצמי של שתי יוצרות המייצבים, ואם הערך העצמי הוא פלוס 1 או
מינוס 1 נקבע על ידי אם השגיאה קומוטטיבית או אנטי-קומוטטיבית עם כל יוצרת מייצב. עבור הראשונה
השגיאה ויוצרת המייצב אנטי-קומוטטיביות, ועבור השנייה הן קומוטטיביות. וזה תמיד יהיה אחד מהשניים כי כל שתי
פעולות Pauli או קומוטטיביות או אנטי-קומוטטיביות. בינתיים המצב psi עצמו לא ממלא תפקיד חשוב
כאן, מלבד העובדה שיוצרות המייצבים פועלות עליו באופן טריוויאלי. אז כשחושבים על
זיהוי שגיאות אנחנו באמת לא צריכים לדאוג לגבי המצב המקודד הספציפי. כל מה שחשוב הוא אם השגיאה קומוטטיבית או אנטי-
קומוטטיבית עם כל יוצרת מייצב. אז בואו נעשה טבלה שיש בה שורה אחת לכל יוצרת מייצב
ועמודה אחת לכל שגיאה. כאן כללתי רק את השגיאות המתאימות להיפוך ביט בודד וגם
ללא שגיאה כלל, שמסומנת על ידי הזהות טנסור עם עצמה שלוש פעמים. היינו יכולים להוסיף עוד עמודות לשגיאות אחרות אם רצינו,
אבל לעת עתה נתמקד רק בשגיאות האלה. הרשומה בטבלה היא או פלוס 1 או מינוס 1, תלוי
ב-אם השגיאה ויוצרת המייצב קומוטטיביות או אנטי-קומוטטיביות. אז לכל שגיאה בטבלה אפשר להסתכל על
העמודה המתאימה כדי לראות איך השגיאה הזו תמיר כל קידוד נתון לוקטור עצמי של פלוס 1 או מינוס 1
של כל יוצרת מייצב. העמודות האלה מתאימות בדיוק לסינדרום שהיינו מקבלים מ
בדיקות הזוגיות, ששקולות למדידות הלא-הרסניות של יוצרות המייצבים כ
נצפים. כמובן שהרשומות בטבלה הזו הן פלוס 1 ומינוס 1 ולא אפסים ואחדות בהתאמה,
ואם מעדיפים אפשר לחשוב על הסינדרומים כמחרוזות הבינאריות המתאימות ולא כעמודות של פלוס 1 ומינוס 1. אבל יש
התאמה ישירה, ורק כדי לעשות את הקשר בין הסינדרומים לערכים העצמיים יותר ברור וישיר
אני אתייחס לוקטורים האלה של פלוס 1 ומינוס 1 כסינדרומים. כמו קודם הסינדרומים אומרים
לנו משהו על כל שגיאה שהתרחשה, ובפרט אם יודעים שאחת מארבע השגיאות האפשריות האלה
התרחשה, הסינדרום מציין לנו איזו, ואפשר לתקן אותה על ידי הפעלת השגיאה שוב אם
נבחר. עכשיו אגיד עוד קצת על הסינדרומים ובפרט נסתכל מקרוב על
ההיבטים האלגבריים שלהם. הקידודים שלנו הם מצבי 3 qubit-ים, אז הם וקטורי יחידה במרחב
וקטורי מרוכב בן 8 ממדים. ומה שארבעת הסינדרומים האפשריים עושים הוא לחלק את המרחב בן 8 הממדים הזה
לארבעה תת-מרחבים דו-ממדיים, כלומר הוקטורים בכל אחד מתת-המרחבים האלה תמיד יתנו לנו את אותו
סינדרום. ביתר פירוט, הדיאגרמה הזו ממחישה איך המרחב בן 8 הממדים מחולק.
כל יוצרת מייצב מפצלת את המרחב לשני תת-מרחבים בממד שווה, כלומר המרחב של וקטורים עצמיים של פלוס 1
והמרחב של וקטורים עצמיים של מינוס 1. לדוגמה, וקטורי פלוס 1 של ZZ-Identity הם צירופים לינאריים
של מצבי בסיס סטנדרטי שבהם שני הביטים השמאליים ביותר בעלי זוגיות זוגית, והוקטורים העצמיים של מינוס 1 הם צירופים
לינאריים של מצבי בסיס סטנדרטי שבהם שני הביטים השמאליים ביותר בעלי זוגיות אי-זוגית. והמצב דומה עבור
יוצרת המייצב האחרת, חוץ מזה שמדובר בשני הביטים הימניים ביותר ולא השמאליים ביותר. אז ארבעת תת-המרחבים האלה קלים ל
תיאור במקרה הזה, בזכות העובדה שזה קוד מאוד פשוט. בפרט, תת-המרחב
המתאים לסינדרום פלוס 1, פלוס 1 הוא המרחב הנפרש על ידי ket 000 ו-ket 111, שהוא מרחב הקידודים
התקפים והוא נקרא מרחב הקוד. ובאופן כללי, המרחבים נפרשים על ידי מצבי הבסיס הסטנדרטי
שמוצגים בריבועים המתאימים. למרות שזה לא בהכרח כל כך ברור או קל לראות, הסינדרומים
גם מחלקים את כל פעולות Pauli על 3 qubit-ים, שמייצגות את כל שגיאות Pauli האפשריות שיכולות להתרחש, לארבע אוספים בגודל שווה
בהתאם לסינדרום שהשגיאה הזו תגרום. לדוגמה, כל פעולת Pauli
שקומוטטיבית עם שתי יוצרות המייצבים מביאה לסינדרום פלוס 1, פלוס 1. ומבין 64 פעולות Pauli
האפשריות על 3 qubit-ים, יש בדיוק 16 בקטגוריה הזו, כולל שלוש שמוזכרות על המסך. ובאופן דומה עבור שלושת
הסינדרומים האחרים. זה לא ברור מאליו אבל זה נכון, והתכונה הבסיסית הזו שהסינדרומים מחלקים גם את מרחב המצבים
שבו הקידודים חיים וגם את כל שגיאות Pauli האפשריות במרחב לחלקים בגודל שווה היא משהו ש
נכון באופן כללי לקודי מייצבים, שבקרוב נגדיר בדיוק. למרות שזה בעיקר הערת אגב ב
נקודה הזו, שווה להזכיר שפעולות Pauli שקומוטטיביות עם שתי יוצרות המייצבים, או שקול
פעולות Pauli שמביאות לסינדרום פלוס 1, פלוס 1 אבל אינן עצמן פרופורציונליות לאלמנטים של המייצב, מתנהגות בדיוק כמו
פעולות Pauli על qubit בודד על ה-qubit הלוגי שקידדנו. לדוגמה XXX קומוטטיבי עם
שתי יוצרות המייצבים אבל לא פרופורציונלי לשום אלמנט של המייצב, ואכן זה ברור אם
חושבים על הקוד הזה לרגע שההשפעה שיש לפעולה הזו על קידוד שקולה ל-gate X על
ה-qubit הלוגי שקודד. ושוב, זה משהו שמוכלל לכל קודי המייצבים. עכשיו הגיע הזמן להגדיר קודי
מייצבים באופן כללי, והדרך שזה עובד היא שעושים משהו לגמרי אנלוגי למה שדנו עכשיו עבור
קוד החזרה של 3 ביטים, חוץ מזה שבוחרים יוצרות מייצבים שונות שנקרא להן P1
עד PR לצורך ההסבר. יוצרות המייצבים האלה חייבות כולן להיות פעולות Pauli על N qubit-ים
כאשר N הוא מספר ה-qubit-ים שמשמשים לקידוד. ואי אפשר סתם לבחור קבוצה כלשהי של יוצרות מייצבים, הן
חייבות לקיים כמה תנאים בסיסיים. ראשית, יוצרות המייצבים חייבות כולן להיות קומוטטיביות זו עם
זו. במקרה של קוד החזרה של 3 ביטים לא טרחנו לשים לב לזה, אבל זה פשוט לראות ש-ZZ-Identity ו-Identity-
ZZ אכן קומוטטיביים כי Z קומוטטיבי עם עצמו והכול קומוטטיבי עם
הזהות. לקודי מייצבים עם יוצרות מייצבים יותר מסובכות מצד שני, כולל קודים שבהם יש
גם X-ים וגם Z-ים מופיעים ביוצרות המייצבים, זהו תנאי חשוב שצריך
לבדוק. דרך אחת לחשוב על הצורך בתנאי הזה היא שאנחנו הולכים להתייחס ליוצרות המייצבים כנצפים, ועל ידי דרישה שהן
כולן קומוטטיביות אנחנו מבטיחים שהסדר שבו מבצעים את המדידות האלה לא
משנה. שנית, יוצרות המייצבים חייבות ליצור מה שנקרא קבוצת יוצרות מינימלית, מה שאומר שאם נסיר
אחת מהן נקבל מייצב קטן יותר, ודרך אחת לבטא את זה מתמטית מוצגת כאן על
המסך. בהחלט, התנאי הזה לא ממש חיוני לדרך שקוד מייצבים עובד במובן
תפעולי, ולפעמים כן הגיוני לחשוב על קבוצות יוצרות לא-מינימליות כפי שנראה בשיעור הבא. אבל
לצורך ניתוח קודי מייצבים והסבר תכונותיהם אנחנו הולכים להניח שהתנאי הזה
מתקיים. בעצם התנאי הזה מבטיח שכל נצפה שמודדים כדי לקבל את הסינדרום מוסיף
מידע על שגיאות אפשריות, בניגוד להיות מיותר ולתת תוצאות שניתן בקלות להסיק מיוצרות המייצבים האחרות כ
נצפים. ולבסוף, חייב להיות שלפחות וקטור לא-אפסי אחד מקובע על ידי כל
יוצרות המייצבים, וזה מתברר כשקול לדרישה שמינוס 1 כפול הזהות על N qubit-ים
לא מוכלת במייצב. זה לא ברור מאליו, אבל העניין הוא שכן אפשר לבחור קבוצת יוצרות
מינימלית של פעולות Pauli על N qubit-ים שכולן קומוטטיביות זו עם זו, ובכל זאת שום וקטור לא יהיה בו-זמנית וקטור עצמי של פלוס 1
של כולן. ואנחנו לא רוצים להתעסק עם האפשרות הזו כי קודים שאין בהם קידודים תקפים הם לא
מעניינים. אז אלו הדרישות על יוצרות המייצבים עבור קוד מייצבים, ואם אכן יש לנו קבוצת יוצרות ש
מקיימת את התנאים האלה אז יש לנו קוד מייצבים תקף ואפשר לבחון את תכונותיו. יש הרבה
קודי מייצבים שונים עם תכונות מגוונות שהופכות אותם למעניינים או לא, אבל כולם מקיימים תכונות בסיסיות
מסוימות שמזכירות את אלו שכבר צפינו בהן עבור קוד החזרה של 3 ביטים.
נסתכל על כמה דוגמאות בקרוב, אבל לפני כן אזכיר שכשמתייחסים למרחב הקוד של קוד מייצבים הכוונה לתת-מרחב
של מרחב המצבים של N qubit-ים שכולל כל וקטור שהוא בו-זמנית וקטור עצמי של פלוס 1 של כל אחת מ
יוצרות המייצבים. זהו תת-המרחב של מרחב המצבים של N qubit-ים שבו חיים קידודים תקפים, ויהיה לנו עוד מה
להגיד על תת-המרחב הזה ככל שהשיעור ממשיך. עכשיו בואו נסתכל על כמה דוגמאות של קודי
מייצבים. הנה הדוגמה שכבר דנו בה, קוד החזרה הרגיל של 3 ביטים. ואפשר גם לבטא את
הגרסה המשנה של הקוד הזה מהשיעור הקודם, שיכולה לזהות היפוך פאזה במקום היפוך ביט, כקוד מייצבים כפי שמוצג
כאן. הפעם יוצרות המייצבים מודדות נצפי XX ולא נצפי ZZ, אז אלה בעצם
בדיקות זוגיות בבסיס plus/minus ולא בבסיס הסטנדרטי. בשני המקרים אפשר
מיד לראות שיש לנו קוד מייצבים תקף כי יוצרות המייצבים קומוטטיביות, אלו קבוצות יוצרות
מינימליות, ומרחב הקוד לא טריוויאלי כפי שאנחנו כבר יודעים. אבל אפשר גם לראות די בבירור ש
אי אפשר ליצור מינוס 1 כפול הזהות. והנה קוד Shore בן 9 qubit-ים שהוא גם קוד מייצבים
מבוטא על ידי יוצרות מייצבים. במקרה הזה יש לנו בעצם שלושה עותקים של קוד החזרה של
3 ביטים, אחד לכל אחד משלושת הבלוקים של שלושה qubit-ים, וגם שתי יוצרות המייצבים האחרונות ש
לוקחות צורה שמזכירה את ה-circuit שראינו בשיעור הקודם לזיהוי היפוכי פאזה עבור
הקוד. דרך אחרת לחשוב על שתי יוצרות המייצבים האחרונות היא שהן לוקחות בדיוק את אותה צורה כמו
עבור קוד החזרה של 3 ביטים להיפוכי פאזה, חוץ מזה שמחליפים XXX ב-X, והסיבה לכך
היא ש-XXX מתאים לפעולת X על ה-qubit הלוגי שמקודד באמצעות קוד החזרה של 3 ביטים. אבל
זו הערת אגב וזה לא משהו לדאוג לגביו עכשיו למקרה שזה לא ברור. עכשיו נסתכל על עוד כמה
דוגמאות, אבל לפני כן אזכיר שאנשים לעיתים קרובות משמיטים את סמלי המכפלה הטנסורית כשמתארים קודי מייצבים כי זה נוטה
להפוך אותם לקלים יותר לקריאה. אז ככה הקודים האלה נראים בלי סמלי המכפלה הטנסורית,
אבל כמובן שאלה מכפלות טנסוריות ולא כפלי מטריצות רגילים. למשל אנחנו סתם משמיטים את סמלי המכפלה הטנסורית כדי שיהיה פחות
עמוס והתבניות יהיו ברורות יותר. הנה דוגמה נוספת שנקראת
קוד Steane בן 7 qubit-ים, ויש לו כמה תכונות די מרשימות. נחזור לזה
מדי פעם לאורך השיעורים הנותרים של היחידה, אבל לעת עתה אפשר פשוט לוודא שזה קוד מייצבים
תקף. בפרט שלוש יוצרות המייצבים הראשונות ברור שקומוטטיביות זו עם זו כי Z קומוטטיבי עם
עצמו והזהות קומוטטיבית עם הכול, והמצב דומה עבור שלוש האחרונות. אז נשאר
לבדוק שאם לוקחים אחת מיוצרות המייצבים של Z ואחת מיוצרות המייצבים של X אז הן קומוטטיביות,
ומספיק קל לעבור על תשעת הזיווגים האפשריים כדי לבדוק שבכל המקרים האלה תמיד
יהיה X ו-Z מתאימים באותו מיקום מספר זוגי של פעמים, כך ששתי היוצרות יהיו קומוטטיביות בדיוק
כמו ש-XX ו-ZZ קומוטטיביים. זו קבוצת יוצרות מינימלית ויש לה מרחב קוד לא-טריוויאלי, אבל
לא אנסה לנמק את זה בסרטון הזה ובמקום זאת אשאיר את זה לכם לחשוב עליו אם תרצו. קוד Steane בן 7 qubit-ים דומה
לקוד Shore בן 9 qubit-ים במובן שהוא מקודד qubit בודד ומאפשר תיקון של שגיאה שרירותית על qubit אחד, אבל הוא דורש
רק 7 qubit-ים ולא 9. זה לא מספר ה-qubit-ים המינימלי שנדרש כדי שקוד לתיקון שגיאות
יקודד qubit ויתקן שגיאה שרירותית על qubit בודד. הנה קוד מייצבים
שבדרך כלל נקרא פשוט קוד 5 qubit-ים, שגם הוא מקודד qubit בודד ויכול לתקן שגיאה שרירותית על qubit בודד,
ו-5 הוא מספר ה-qubit-ים המינימלי שעבורו זה אפשרי. הנה דוגמה נוספת של
קוד מייצבים, אם כי זה לא באמת קוד כביכול במובן שמרחב הקוד הוא
חד-ממדי. בפרט מרחב הקוד של הקוד הזה הוא המרחב הנפרש על ידי ebit, או במילים אחרות מצב
Bell phi plus. אז אי אפשר באמת לקודד qubit-ים באמצעות הקוד הזה, אבל הוא עדיין קוד מייצבים תקף שמרחב
הקוד שלו הוא חד-ממדי. ואפשר לעשות משהו דומה למצב
GHZ. אז אלו כמה דוגמאות של קודי מייצבים ונראה עוד אינסוף דוגמאות ב
שיעור הבא. נניח שניתן לנו קוד מייצבים. שאלה טבעית לשאול עליו
היא, אולי השאלה הראשונה שעולה בראש, כמה qubit-ים הוא מקודד? לשאלה הזו יש תשובה מאוד פשוטה,
וכדי להסביר אותה בואו נהיה מדויקים לגבי קוד המייצבים הנדון. יש לנו R יוצרות מייצבים
על N qubit-ים P1 עד PR שמקיימות את שלוש הדרישות שהזכרתי קודם, כלומר ש
יוצרות המייצבים כולן קומוטטיביות זו עם זו, שזו קבוצת יוצרות מינימלית כך שלא היינו מקבלים את אותו
מייצב אם היינו מסירים אחת מהיוצרות, ושיש לפחות וקטור לא-אפסי אחד במרחב
הקוד. כפי שמשפט המוצג על המסך מציין, חייב להיות שלמרחב הקוד של קוד המייצבים יש
ממד 2 בחזקת N מינוס R, או דרך אחרת לומר את זה היא שאפשר לקודד N
מינוס R qubit-ים באמצעות הקוד הזה. אז באופן אינטואיטיבי יש לנו N qubit-ים בקידודים וכל
יוצרת מייצב למעשה לוקחת qubit מבחינת כמה qubit-ים אפשר לקודד.
המשפט הזה לא כל כך קשה להוכחה, ואראה לכם הוכחה עוד רגע. אבל קודם נסתכל על כמה
דוגמאות ונתחיל עם קוד החזרה הרגיל של 3 ביטים. יש לנו 3 qubit-ים ב
קידודים, אז N שווה ל-3 ויש R שווה ל-2 יוצרות מייצבים, ולכן אפשר לקודד qubit
אחד באמצעות הקוד הזה. שימו לב שזה לא קשור לאילו שגיאות או כמה שגיאות אפשר לזהות או
לתקן, זה עניין אחר. זו רק הצהרה על ממד מרחב
הקוד. לדוגמה נוספת, שקלו את קוד 5 qubit-ים. כאן יש לנו 5 qubit-ים ו-4
יוצרות מייצבים, אז שוב למרחב הקוד יש ממד 2, מה שאומר שאפשר לקודד qubit אחד באמצעות
הקוד הזה. ועוד דוגמה לעת עתה, עבור קוד המייצבים של ebit יש לנו 2 qubit-ים ו-2 יוצרות מייצבים, אז
מרחב הקוד הוא חד-ממדי, וכפי שהזכרתי קודם זהו המרחב הנפרש על ידי מצב Bell phi plus.
נראה עוד דוגמאות ככל שנמשיך, כולל קודים שבהם אפשר לקודד יותר מ-qubit אחד. אבל לעת עתה בואו
נראה איך אפשר להוכיח את המשפט. הדבר הראשון שצריך לשים לב אליו הוא שבגלל שיוצרות
המייצבים קומוטטיביות ויוצרות קבוצת יוצרות מינימלית, ובגלל שכל פעולת Pauli היא ההופכי של עצמה, כל
אלמנט במייצב ניתן לביטוי בצורה יחידה כמכפלה שבה מעלים כל יוצרת מייצב
PK בחזקת AK כאשר כל AK הוא או 0 או 1, ואז מכפילים את התוצאות
יחד. דרך אחרת לומר את זה היא שמקבלים כל אלמנט של המייצב על ידי הכפלת תת-קבוצה כלשהי של
יוצרות המייצבים, ואף פעם לא מקבלים את אותו אלמנט מייצב מתת-קבוצות שונות. ודבר אחד ש
זה גורר הוא שהדרך היחידה לבטא את פעולת הזהות על N qubit-ים בצורה הזו היא לקחת את כל החזקות להיות
אפס. עכשיו נגדיר pi-K להיות ההטלה על המרחב העצמי של פלוס 1 של PK לכל K מ-1 עד R, ויש
נוסחה פשוטה להטלה הזו: אפשר פשוט למצע את PK עם הזהות על N qubit-ים, מה שלמעשה משאיר את
הערכים העצמיים של פלוס 1 כמו שהם ומזיז את כל הערכים העצמיים של מינוס 1 ל
אפס. עכשיו, מרחב הקוד מוגדר כקבוצת כל הוקטורים שהם בו-זמנית וקטורים עצמיים של פלוס 1 של כל
יוצרות המייצבים. בהינתן שיוצרות המייצבים קומוטטיביות, גם ההטלות חייבות להיות קומוטטיביות, וזה
גורר שהמכפלה של ההטלות האלה היא גם כן הטלה, ובפרט זו ההטלה על
החיתוך של תת-המרחבים שההטלות הבודדות מטילות עליהם, או במילים אחרות זו ההטלה על
מרחב הקוד. אפשר לפרוש את המכפלה הזו, ומה שמקבלים הוא הממוצע על כל
אלמנט של המייצב. ולבסוף, בגלל שהממד של כל תת-מרחב שווה ל
עקבה של ההטלה על אותו תת-מרחב, אנחנו מוצאים שממד מרחב הקוד הוא הממוצע של העקבות על אלמנטי
המייצב. אבל למעט פעולת הזהות על N qubit-ים, לכל אלמנטי המייצב חייבת להיות
עקבה שווה לאפס, כי שלוש מטריצות Pauli שאינן זהות כולן בעלות עקבה אפס. העקבה של פעולת הזהות על N qubit-ים
היא 2 בחזקת N, ולכן אנחנו מוצאים שממד מרחב הקוד הוא 2 בחזקת N מינוס R, מה שמוכיח את
המשפט. עכשיו אגיד עוד קצת על איך אפשר לקודד qubit-ים באמצעות קודי מייצבים, אבל כדי לעשות את זה קודם
צריך להציג פעולות Clifford. פעולות Clifford הן פעולות יוניטריות על כל מספר של
qubit-ים שניתנות למימוש על ידי circuit-ים קוונטיים עם קבוצה מוגבלת של gate-ים, כלומר gate-י Hadamard, gate-י S
ו-gate-י controlled-NOT. שימו לב ש-gate-י T לא כלולים, וגם לא gate-י Toffoli או gate-י
Fredkin. ולא רק שה-gate-ים האלה לא כלולים ברשימה הזו, אלא שלמעשה אי אפשר לממש את ה-gate-ים האלה
באמצעות אלה שברשימה כאן, אז הם לא פעולות Clifford. פעולות Pauli מצד שני
הן כן פעולות Clifford, וספציפית אפשר לממש אותן באמצעות רצפים של gate-י Hadamard ו-gate-י
S. אז זו דרך פשוטה להגדיר פעולות Clifford, אבל זה לא ממש מסביר למה הן מוגדרות כ
כך או מה מיוחד באוסף הספציפי הזה של gate-ים. הנה הסיבה האמיתית שפעולות Clifford מוגדרות
ככה: עד כדי פאזה גלובלית, פעולות Clifford על N qubit-ים הן בדיוק הפעולות
היוניטריות שתמיד ממירות פעולות Pauli לפעולות Pauli על ידי צמידות. ליתר דיוק, פעולה
יוניטרית U על N qubit-ים היא פעולת Clifford עד כדי גורם פאזה גלובלית אם ורק אם לכל פעולת Pauli על N qubit-ים,
צמידות של פעולת Pauli זו על ידי U נותנת לנו פלוס או מינוס 1 כפול פעולת Pauli
אחרת אולי שונה על N qubit-ים. אפשר בקלות לבדוק שהתכונה הזו נכונה עבור gate-י Hadamard, gate-י
S ו-gate-י controlled-NOT, אז היא בהכרח מתקיימת עבור circuit-ים שבנויים מה-gate-ים האלה. מה שיותר קשה להוכיח הוא שזה
הולך בכיוון ההפוך, כלומר שאם נתונה פעולה יוניטרית מסוימת U על N qubit-ים שמקיימת את
התכונה הזו, אז חייב להיות אפשרי לממש אותה עד כדי פאזה גלובלית באמצעות רק gate-י Hadamard, S ו-controlled-NOT.
לא אעבור על ההוכחה של הגרירה הזו, אבל היא נכונה ואפשר לחפש אותה אם
מעניין אתכם. פעולות Clifford אינן אוניברסליות לחישוב קוונטי, כלומר אי אפשר להריץ חישובים
קוונטיים שרירותיים באמצעות רק gate-י Hadamard, S ו-controlled-NOT. למעשה, עבור ערך נתון של N יש רק מספר סופי של
פעולות Clifford על N qubit-ים, אז זו קבוצה בדידה של פעולות. אז בניגוד ל
קבוצה אוניברסלית של gate-ים קוונטיים, אי אפשר לקרב פעולות יוניטריות שרירותיות לכל רמת דיוק רצויה. ולמעשה
ביצוע פעולות Clifford על מצבי בסיס סטנדרטי ואחריהן מדידות בסיס סטנדרטי לא יכול לאפשר
לנו לבצע חישובים שמעבר להישג ידם של אלגוריתמים קלאסיים, כי אפשר לסמלץ ביעילות חישובים מהסוג הזה
באופן קלאסי. העובדה הזו ידועה כמשפט Gottesman-Knill, וההוכחה הסטנדרטית של המשפט הזה מבוססת במובן מסוים
על פורמליזם המייצבים. בפרט, הדרך שזה עובד היא שאפשר לעקוב אחרי הדרך שפעולות Clifford ממירות פעולות
Pauli על ידי צמידות, מה שאפשר לעשות ביעילות, ואז להסיק מזה מה החישובים עושים ל
qubit-ים. אז מה הקשר של כל זה לקודי מייצבים? ובכן, קוד מייצבים נותן לנו
מרחב קוד בממד מסוים, ויש לנו את החופש להשתמש במרחב הקוד הזה איך שנבחר. אז שום דבר לא מכריח אותנו לקודד
qubit-ים למרחב הזה בצורה ספציפית. אבל תמיד יהיה אפשרי לבצע קידוד באמצעות פעולת Clifford
כמקודד. וזה נחמד כי פעולות Clifford פשוטות יחסית בהשוואה לפעולות יוניטריות
שרירותיות. יש דרכים לייעל את המימוש שלהן שעובדות לאורך קווים דומים להוכחת משפט
Gottesman-Knill, וכתוצאה מכך circuit-ים למימוש שלהן אף פעם לא צריכים להיות גדולים
במיוחד. בפרט תמיד אפשר לבצע קידוד באמצעות פעולת Clifford שדורשת קצת פחות ממספר ריבועי של gate-ים,
כי זה בעצם נכון לכל פעולת Clifford. אז המסקנה היא שעבור קוד מייצבים נתון, תמיד
אפשר לקודד qubit-ים ביעילות באמצעות הקוד הזה, והכלים המתמטיים שמועילים להבנת פעולות Clifford יכולים לעזור עם
התהליך הזה. לדוגמה, הנה מקודד עבור קוד Steane בן 7 qubit-ים. זו פעולת Clifford, וכפי שמתברר
זו אפילו לא צריכה gate-י S. עבור קודי מייצבים כלליים, זיהוי שגיאות עובד בצורה
הבאה. כמו קודם נניח שיש לנו N יוצרות מייצבים על N qubit-ים P1 עד PR, וניתן ל-E להיות פעולת Pauli
על N qubit-ים שמייצגת שגיאה היפותטית על קידוד. אנחנו מתייחסים רק לפעולות
Pauli כשגיאות אגב, כי הדיסקרטיזציה של שגיאות עובדת באותה דרך עבור קודי מייצבים שרירותיים כמו עבור קוד Shore בן 9 qubit-ים.
הדרך שבודקים שגיאות היא למדוד כל אחת מיוצרות המייצבים כ
נצפים. יש R יוצרות מייצבים, אז זה אומר R תוצאות כאשר כל אחת היא פלוס 1 או מינוס
1, או ערך בינארי אם מעדיפים לשייך 0 לפלוס 1 ו-1 למינוס 1. ו-R התוצאות האלה
ביחד יוצרות את הסינדרום, בדיוק כמו שהיה לנו עבור קוד החזרה של 3 ביטים כאשר R היה שווה
ל-2. באופן כללי יש שלוש אפשרויות לשגיאה E מבחינת זיהויה, והן כדלקמן. ראשית,
ייתכן ש-E נמצאת במייצב, כלומר שאפשר ליצור את E מיוצרות המייצבים, או
באופן כללי קצת יותר, ייתכן ש-E שקולה לאלמנט מייצב עד כדי פאזה
גלובלית. במקרה הזה E היא לא באמת שגיאה כלל כי אין לה השפעה במרחב הקוד מלבד אולי
הזרקת פאזה גלובלית שאין לה שום השפעה. אז לא צריך לדאוג בכלל משגיאות כאלה. כל
פעולה לא-טריוויאלית שיש לה קורה מחוץ למרחב הקוד, אז זה לא מדאיג
אותנו. הרבה יותר מדאיגה האפשרות ש-E לא נמצאת במייצב אפילו לא עד כדי פאזה גלובלית, אבל
בכל זאת היא קומוטטיבית עם כל אחת ואחת מיוצרות המייצבים שלנו. זכרו שזו
האנטי-קומוטטיביות של השגיאה עם יוצרת מייצב שגורמת למינוס 1 להופיע איפשהו בסינדרום,
אבל זה לא קורה במקרה הזה. אז זו שגיאה שבאמת משנה וקטורים במרחב הקוד בצורה
לא-טריוויאלית, ואנחנו יודעים את זה כי אחרת היא הייתה פרופורציונלית לאלמנט מייצב. אבל היא עוברת
ללא זיהוי על ידי הקוד. אז זה המקרה הרע. יש לנו שגיאה שאולי משנה
את המידע הקוונטי שקידדנו, אבל הקוד עיוור לעובדה הזו. לדוגמה, עבור קוד החזרה של
3 ביטים, XXX נופלת לקטגוריה הזו. והאפשרות האחרונה היא שה-E
אנטי-קומוטטיבית עם לפחות אחת מיוצרות המייצבים, וזה אומר שהקוד מזהה את השגיאה הזו כי
נקבל סינדרום עם לפחות מינוס 1 אחד איפשהו בו, מה שמציין שמשהו לא בסדר ונצטרך לנסות לתקן את השגיאה הזו
איכשהו. אז אלה האפשרויות. מבחינת טרמינולוגיה,
כשמתייחסים למרחק של קוד מייצבים הכוונה למשקל המינימלי של פעולת Pauli שנופלת
לקטגוריה השנייה, כלומר שהיא משנה את מרחב הקוד בצורה לא-טריוויאלית אבל הקוד לא
מזהה את זה. וכשאומרים שקוד מייצבים הוא קוד מייצבים [[n,m,d]] באמצעות
סוגריים מרובעים כפולים כפי שמוצג על המסך, הכוונה היא שקידודים הם באורך N qubit-ים,
הקוד מסוגל לקודד M qubit-ים כך שלמרחב הקוד יש ממד 2 בחזקת M, והמרחק שלו הוא D. אז שגיאה חייבת
להיות במשקל D או יותר כדי לשנות את המצב הלוגי של כל qubit שקידדנו מבלי שתזוהה כ
שגיאה. עכשיו נסתכל על קוד Steane בן 7 qubit-ים כדוגמה ונקבע מה המרחק
שלו. הנה יוצרות המייצבים עבור הקוד הזה, וזכרו שהמרחק הוא המשקל המינימלי של
פעולת Pauli על N qubit-ים שקומוטטיבית עם כל יוצרות המייצבים אבל אינה עצמה במייצב ולא
פרופורציונלית לאלמנט של המייצב. מה שנקבע הוא שלקוד הזה יש מרחק
3. הדרך שנקבע את זה היא קודם לשקול כל פעולת Pauli במשקל לכל היותר 2 ו
להסיק שהדרך היחידה שהיא יכולה להיות קומוטטיבית עם כל שש יוצרות המייצבים היא שתהיה הזהות, שתמיד היא אלמנט של
המייצב. אז נניח שמטריצות Pauli שאולי אינן זהות שיוצרות את הפעולה הזו שנקרא
להן P ו-Q, מופיעות בשני המיקומים השמאליים ביותר. זה רק מקרה אחד וכן צריך
לשקול את כל המיקומים האחרים האפשריים למטריצות Pauli שאולי אינן זהות, אבל הטיעון בעצם אותו דבר לכל
המיקומים האפשריים. ובכן, לפי ההנחה הפעולה הזו קומוטטיבית עם כל שש
יוצרות המייצבים, אז בפרט היא קומוטטיבית עם זו וגם קומוטטיבית עם
זו. Q מתיישרת עם מטריצת הזהות בשתי היוצרות האלה, ולכן בחרנו את השתיים האלה. ויש לנו מטריצות
זהות בחמשת המיקומים הימניים ביותר של השגיאה הזו, ואז מסיקים ש-P חייבת להיות קומוטטיבית גם עם X
וגם עם Z, כי אחרת השגיאה הזו הייתה אנטי-קומוטטיבית עם אחת משתי היוצרות האלה. אבל מטריצת Pauli היחידה ש
קומוטטיבית גם עם X וגם עם Z היא הזהות, אז P חייבת להיות הזהות. ועכשיו שאנחנו יודעים את זה
אפשר לבחור עוד שתי יוצרות מייצבים שיש להן X ו-Z במיקום השני משמאל, ואפשר
להסיק מסקנה דומה לגבי Q. אז אין דרך לשגיאה במשקל לכל היותר 2 לעבור ללא זיהוי על ידי הקוד הזה,
אלא אם היא פשוט פעולת הזהות שנמצאת במייצב, אז זו לא באמת
שגיאה. מצד שני, יש פעולות Pauli במשקל 3 שקומוטטיביות עם כל שש יוצרות המייצבים האלה
אבל לא פרופורציונליות לאלמנטי מייצב, והנה שתי דוגמאות. אז הסקנו שלקוד
הזה יש מרחק 3. הדבר האחרון שנדון בו בשיעור הזה הוא תיקון שגיאות עבור
קודי מייצבים. כרגיל נניח שהקוד שלנו מצוין על ידי יוצרות מייצבים על N qubit-ים
P1 עד PR, ונתחיל בלחשוב קצת על כל השגיאות האפשריות שיכולות
להתרחש. יש 2 בחזקת R סינדרומים אפשריים, וכפי שהזכרתי קודם בשיעור הסינדרומים האלה מחלקים את כל
פעולות Pauli האפשריות על N qubit-ים לאוספים בגודל שווה, כך שזה אומר 4 בחזקת N חלקי 2 בחזקת R פעולות Pauli
בתוך כל קבוצה. אז כשרואים סינדרום מסוים, ייתכן שכל אחת מ-4 בחזקת N חלקי 2
בחזקת R שגיאות אלה אחראית. אנחנו סופרים קצת יותר מדי כאן כי חלק מהשגיאות
האלה בעלות בדיוק אותה השפעה על מרחב הקוד. בפרט אם יש לנו שגיאה E ומכפילים את E בכל
אלמנט מייצב S, אז נקבל שגיאה אחרת שיש לה בדיוק אותה השפעה במרחב הקוד כמו ל-E. אז
אלה שגיאות שקולות. למייצב יש 2 בחזקת R אלמנטים, ואם מתחשבים בזה אז מוצאים
שלכל סינדרום יש 4 בחזקת N מינוס R מחלקות שקילות לא-שקולות של שגיאות שהיו יכולות לגרום לאותו
סינדרום. ומה שזה אומר הוא שאלא אם R שווה ל-N, ובמקרה כזה מרחב הקוד חד-ממדי ו
לכן אי אפשר לקודד אף qubit בכלל, זה לא הולך להיות אפשרי לתקן כל שגיאה שאפשר לזהות. במקום זאת
מה שצריך לעשות הוא לבחור רק פעולת תיקון אחת לכל סינדרום, בתקווה לתקן רק מחלקה אחת של שגיאות
שקולות. אז איך צריך לבחור איזה תיקון לבצע לכל סינדרום? אסטרטגיה טבעית היא לבחור
את פעולת Pauli במשקל הנמוך ביותר שגורמת לכל סינדרום שנמדד, עם הרעיון שפעולות Pauli במשקל נמוך יותר
מייצגות הסברים סבירים יותר לאותו סינדרום. ייתכן שזה לא באמת
המצב עבור מודלים מסוימים של רעש, ואסטרטגיה טבעית אחרת היא לחשב איכשהו את השגיאה הסבירה ביותר שגורמת ל
סינדרום הנתון. אבל לעת עתה רק נשקול את האסטרטגיה שבה מנסים לתקן שגיאות על ידי בחירת פעולת Pauli במשקל הנמוך ביותר שגורמת ל
סינדרום. עבור קוד מייצבים במרחק D, האסטרטגיה הזו תמיד תאפשר לנו לתקן שגיאות במשקל הקטן
בהחלט מחצי D, או במילים אחרות במשקל לכל היותר D מינוס 1 חלקי 2, ואסביר בקצרה למה
כך. זה יראה למשל שקוד Steane בן 7 qubit-ים יכול לתקן כל שגיאת Pauli במשקל 1, ובזכות
הדיסקרטיזציה של שגיאות, זה אומר שבדיוק כמו קוד Shore בן 9 qubit-ים, קוד Steane יכול לתקן שגיאה שרירותית
על qubit אחד. אז ככה זה עובד. שקלו שהעיגול הזה מייצג את כל פעולות Pauli
האפשריות שמביאות לסינדרום של הכול-פלוס-1, שהוא הסינדרום שמרמז שלא התרחשו שגיאות
ושום דבר לא בסדר. בין הפעולות האלה יש אלמנטים של המייצב, או ליתר דיוק
פעולות שפרופורציונליות לאלמנטים של המייצב. ויש גם שגיאות לא-טריוויאליות שמשנות את מרחב הקוד איכשהו אבל הן לא
מזוהות על ידי הקוד. ואנחנו יודעים לפי הגדרת המרחק שלכל פעולת Pauli בקטגוריה הזו חייב להיות משקל לפחות
D, כי D מוגדר כמשקל המינימלי של הפעולות האלה. יש לנו גם פעולות Pauli
שגורמות לסינדרומים אחרים להופיע, ואפשר לשקול כל סינדרום בתורו אם רוצים, אבל כאן אנחנו רק מדמיינים
שסינדרום כלשהו S הופיע. עכשיו דמיינו ש-E היא שגיאה ב
קטגוריה הזו שיש לה משקל הקטן בהחלט מחצי המרחק D. ובכן, אנחנו לא יודעים שזו
בהכרח פעולת Pauli במשקל מינימלי בעיגול הזה, אז ניקח C להיות הפעולה במשקל מינימלי בקבוצה הזו, או אחת מהן במקרה של
שוויון. אז ייתכן ש-C שווה ל-E ואולי לא. אבל בגלל ש-C בעלת
משקל מינימלי, אנחנו יודעים שאין סיכוי שיש לה משקל גדול יותר ממשקל E, כי C גם היא בקבוצה
ויש לה משקל מינימלי. אז לפעולת התיקון C חייב להיות משקל הקטן בהחלט מחצי
D. אז מה קורה אם מפעילים את התיקון הזה C על כל מה שהמצב שלנו הפך להיות אחרי השגיאה E?
התשובה היא שהמצב שמקבלים הוא C כפול E מוכפל בקידוד המקורי, כי קודם
הכפלנו ב-E, זו הייתה השגיאה, ואז הכפלנו ב-C כדי לנסות לתקן. והמכפלה הזו חייבת להיות ב
מייצב או פרופורציונלית לאלמנט של המייצב, והנה למה. ראשית, בגלל ש-E ו-C נותנות לנו את
אותו סינדרום, C כפול E חייבת לתת את סינדרום הכול-פלוס-1. זה בגלל שעבור
יוצרת מייצב נתונה, או ש-C ו-E שתיהן קומוטטיביות עם אותה יוצרת או ששתיהן אנטי-קומוטטיביות. זה חייב להיות אותו דבר ל
שתיהן כי הסינדרומים זהים, ואם חושבים על זה רגע זה גורר ש-C כפול E חייבת
להיות קומוטטיבית עם כל יוצרות המייצבים. ולבסוף, C כפול E חייבת להיות
למטה במייצב כי המשקל שלה לא יכול להיות גדול מסכום המשקלות של C ו-E, ולכן המשקל שלה
קטן בהחלט מ-D. וזה אומר שתיקנו בהצלחה את E, כי הפעלת E ואז C לא עושה כלום ל
מרחב הקוד. אז זה מצוין, אבל יש רק בעיה אחת והיא שעבור קודי
מייצבים באופן כללי, זו בעיה קשה חישובית לחשב את הפעולה במשקל הנמוך ביותר שגורמת לסינדרום
נתון. ואכן, זה נכון אפילו עבור קודים קלאסיים שבהקשר הזה אפשר לחשוב עליהם כקודי מייצבים
שבהם רק מטריצות זהות ומטריצות Pauli-Z מופיעות כגורמי טנסור בתוך יוצרות
המייצבים. אז בניגוד לשלב הקידוד, פעולות Clifford לא באות להציל אותנו הפעם, והפתרון הסביר
היחיד הוא לבחור קודים ספציפיים שעבורם אפשר לחשב תיקונים טובים ביעילות. ואין מתכון ל
זה. פשוט, פיתוח קודי מייצבים כאלה הוא חלק מהאומנות
של עיצוב קודים קוונטיים. וזה מקום טוב לעצור בשיעור הזה. אני מקווה שתצטרפו אלי
לשיעור הבא שבו נסתכל על כמה בניות ספציפיות של קודים קוונטיים, כולל קודים שממחישים את האומנות של עיצוב קודים קוונטיים
בצורה די מרהיבה. להתראות לעת עתה.